voici la jeune fille au premier rang les
initiales de la star peintes sur la joue
en train de l'interpeller pour monter
sur scène emeline n'a alors que 14 ans
des enfants
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
jeudi les enfants en près de 15 ans
comble de l'histoire c'est sous les airs
de papa chanteur que pour la première
fois emeline se retrouvent sur scène aux
côtés de son idole
emeline et dosanjh et vous allez voir
que ce n'est qu'un début
jean luc lahaye va d'ailleurs présenté
sa nouvelle danseuse au public à sa
façon
vous les avez découverts sur mes côtés
massoud jeunes recrues j'ai encore
répondu
pendant plus d'un an emeline de 14 à 15
ans vinci danser à de multiples reprises
pour le chanteur
alors merci vincent martens d'être avec
nous on va revenir sur ce dock merci
d'être là et que vous avez suivi hier
soir bien entendu et je crois que les
suivis avec avec jean-luc on a beaucoup
beaucoup d'extraits alors hier il y
avait un documentaire sur w9 qui
s'intitule est
une idole jean luc lahaye et c'est pas
la peine de avec le chanteur a été
vraiment venir n'a pas posé de questions
là dessus alors le truc c'est pas
possible toulouse mais la question
commence à me faire chier
cette adolescente donc de 14 ans quand
même voir vous avez vu si vous avez dit
avec nous il ya un instant qu'ils
étaient montés sur scène pour voilà lors
d'un conseil qui était venu ça dans une
de ses danseuses ensuite elle s'appelle
emeline à la rencontre est donc le
chanteur assez tôt puisque voilà c'était
c'était à ce moment là ils vont pourtant
se voir souvent et quelques années plus
tard elle il dit dans le documentaire
qu'elle portera plainte pour des
dizaines de viol qu'elle aurait subi ne
l'a pas du chanteur regardez ce qu'ils
disaient
c'est à l'âge de 13 ans qu'emmeline
découvre jean luc lahaye
mal dans sa peau la jeune adolescente
s'évade à travers ses chansons elle va
tous ses concerts elle se fait remarquer
ça devient une espèce de rituels entre
eux mêmes les amis de cette jeune fils
l'appel lolita light et méline est
repéré par la star et selon elle ce
n'est que trois ans plus tard que son
calvaire aurait débuté
elle accuse le chanteur savard eu des
rapports sexuels particulièrement
brutaux avec elles indique que cela
s'est déroulé cinquantaine de fois
environ parfois chez elle parfois chez
le chanteur parfois même dans les loges
alors merci vincent vous êtes un ami de
proches de jean luc vous avez vu le
documentaire oui j'ai vu le documentaire
vous en avez pensé avoir d'autres
extraits dans un instant que vous en
avez pensé j'ai pensé déjà que la
journaliste qui a fait ce documentaire a
travaillé d'accord contrairement à karl
zéro qui est venue la semaine dernière
c'est un ami mais rien à faire la promo
de son bouquin et tout mélanger donc ils
ont bossé sur le documentaire j'ai
trouvé que j'ai trouvé relativement
objectif d'accor et après donc quand on
parle de ce passage cette jeune fille
qui danse et qui avait 13 ans et c'est
sa mère qui l'emmenait avec qui
connaissait jean luc qui l'emmenait au
concert et là ce moment là elle dansait
il l'a rencontrée seulement après trois
ans près ce qui ramène déjà à 16 ans et
quelques donc pour ramener les choses à
leur place et c'est la mère qui l'a mené
à tous les concerts et comme tous les
jeunes montent sur celle là pour chanter
c'est sur une chanson qui s'appelle papa
chanteur c'est pour ça qu'il dit est ce
qu'il ya des jeunes de 14 ans pourront
faire pour la chanson parce que sorti
les images du contexte on peut
travailler quand il dit est ce qu'il ya
des enfants de 14 ans qui peut monter
sur scène c'est par rapport à une seule
chanson et c'est là qu'il ait fait
monter alors wwf a diffusé une archive
où l'on voit la rencontre entre le club
et cette jeune fille regardez
cette jeune fille devant la star
nous l'appellerons emeline pour la
protéger à l'époque elle vient d'avoir
16 ans jean luc lahaye lui 64
seulement si à l'époque elle était une
fan inconditionnelle
aujourd'hui emeline porte plainte pour
viol contre le chanteur
jean-luc là elle invite alors à
l'attendre dehors
[Musique]
à sa sortie l'artiste est assailli par
ses fans mais d'après ces images il n'a
d'yeux que pour l'agenais mlyn au point
d'aller la chercher dans la foule
ces images sont d'autant plus choquant
qu'une autre jeune fille mineure à
l'époque des faits présumés prétend elle
aussi avoir été abusée par le chanteur
qui se retrouve aujourd'hui en pleine
tempête judiciaire
donc c'est la même jeune fille emeline
oui gilles verdez c'était une grande
force du reportage c'est que ils ont
c'est à étampes donc lors d'un conseil
dont l'image de la rencontre de jean luc
lahaye avec l'une des deux plaignantes
il faut savoir que la maman de cette
plaignante
qui aurait poussé un peu jean luc fins
sa fille vers jean luc lahaye c'est ça
la thèse du reportage est elle aussi
mise en examen pour non dénonciation de
crime donc le reportage en fait moi je
les trouvais intéressant parce qu'il
était ni à charge ni à décharge ils
étaient équilibrés jean luc lahaye l'a
donc est sorti de prison moi j'ai voulu
avoir des des éléments par son avocat il
n'y a pas de triomphalisme chez les
enfants les infos par vincent absolument
un instant juste un extrait qui a fait
énormément parler aussi ces documents
tourné lors d'un autre concert du
chanteur où il regardé c'était lors d'un
concert
[Applaudissements]
jolie danseuse
[Musique]
très minces importe quoi tribu pense
temps après tu
verras c'est sympa comme jeu d enfant
vous vous tournez vous
êtes
alors oui lorsqu'il ya bien dans le
documentaire c'est qu'il assume son
attirance pour les jeunes femmes de
manière totalement décomplexée on le
voit dans la scène de la séance de
dédicaces on le voit sur la salle des
concerts et lui sa ligne de défense et
qu'ils ne connaissaient pas toujours là
ce jeu ces jeunes femmes et parfois il
les accuse d'avoir menti alors dit
qu'elle était majeure alors qu'elle
était mineure en l'occurrence les deux
jeunes femmes qui ont qui ont porté
plainte l'ont contacté par facebook en
trompant sur leur âge en le défendant
une première fois en disant qu'elle
avait menti sur leur âge une première
fois et en envoyant des photos etc
peut-être même poussés par leur mère ça
je ne sais pas mais en plus c'est une
génération les années 70-80 ils l'ont
dit dans le reportage des chansons de de
léo ferré de charles aznavour ou pas
tous ces chanteurs que je paye mes fils
de sazh ample alors si vous avez parlé
de 17 ans je dis là franchement si on
n'est pas hypocrite avoir vous avez vous
aurez tout à l'époque vous avez des vous
avez parlé de facebook le documentaire
évoque également des échanges de
messages entre jean luc lahaye et
roxanne une autre fille qui accuse le
chanteur est d'ailleurs sous le feu des
projecteurs car facebook l'a dénoncé
regarder
chose rarissime c'est le géant facebook
qui l'aurait dénoncé ils ont constaté
des échanges suspects entre jean luc
lahaye et une jeune fille des photos à
caractère pornographique
la découverte est d'autant plus
choquante qu'à l'époque elle n'a pas
encore 15 ans il va devenir une
véritable idole pour elle si bien et
bien qu'elle ne va pas hésiter à ajouter
jean luc lahaye sur facebook ok une
enquête ces ordinateurs sont saisis mais
il retrouve effectivement les échanges
de photos très suggestives
il la banque en lui demandant sa date de
naissance en dix ans est important que
tu me la donne parce que 1 - tu sais le
pénal j'en ai peur tu me trouves comment
habiller montre-toi nu en vo mois des
photos avant 23 heures mes hôtes les
photos
vous n'avez rien demandé rien demande
vous n'avez rien sollicité jamais vous
nous avez dit la vérité ce matin toute
la vérité je le jure
[Musique]
sur l'âge facebook était plus au courant
sur l'âge que jean luc lahaye puisque à
lui redonner un autre enjeu majeur mais
ils m'ont quand même à il manque quand
même puisque une union l'une dit est-ce
que vous avez sollicité les photos et
demandé des photos nues pas du tout
jamais et après quand après un choc
facebook c'est lui qui dit comment tu me
trouves habillé on voit moins des photos
et après ça continue encore elle lui dit
mais ce que est ce que tu te vois
peut-être vivre un jour avec moi envoie
des photos il renvoie encore il ment
aussi là peut-être qu'il a menti un jeu
pas le hamas mais je veux dire il
pensait qu'elle était majeure à ce
moment là à passer l'éternité majeur
après moi je suis pas là non plus j'ai
des enfants etc moi je suis pas là pour
défendre quelqu'un qui saurait des
mineurs et je cautionne pas ça du tout
je suis pas je suis là parce qu'on m'a
demandé déjà ça manger pas je suis à
saint tropez
traqué nul autrefois lui là bas il vaut
mieux que j'aille moi je me suis dit
vaut mieux que je manque mois ci c'est
un pote et c'est pour ça que je suis non
moi j'ai du travail
vous avez des infos sur la suite de look
est alors maintenant il n'a pas été
libéré par hasard et ça c'est des infos
c'est presqu'un semaines que j'ai il a
été libéré parce que justement ces
ordinateurs ont été étudiés ces disques
durs etc
il ya comme ses filles avait 16 ans
comme facebook les a dénoncés elles sont
venues le défendre ces deux mêmes jeunes
femmes elles sont venues le défendre
avec les maires et tout le procureur lui
a continué donc il a pris huit mois de
sursis ma malgré que les pays a fait des
lettres etc dix ans après comme il s'est
mis en couple avec une autre jeune femme
qui s'appelle paula qu'il ya une
trentaine d'années
les deux filles se sont concertés ils
ont les preuves maintenant elles se sont
téléphonés dix ans après c'est à dire
l'année dernière 1 pour porter plainte
parce qu'elle avait les moules les
imaginer leur vie c'est des fans mars ou
emprises forcément quand on est fan on
est on est sous emprise elles se sont
imaginé faire leur vie avec il s'est mis
avec une autre jeune femme depuis il n'a
pas bougé depuis dix ans elle fait du
parachutisme et fait des trucs et ses
fils se sont concertés et alors le truc
bizarre c'est qu'ils l'ont relâché je
vais vous dire pourquoi parce que les
ordinateurs ont été étudiés les trucs et
ça on verra pas ce qu'il ya encore un
mois en arrière johnny depp il était
foutu
il y avait plus de plan de carrière plus
rien donc on verra par la suite les
ordinateurs ont été étudiés il s'avère
que un ou deux mois avant que ces jeunes
femmes portent plainte dix ans après
alors qu'elle avait défendue disant non
il y en a encore une des deux qui lui
envoyait à peu près 950 mails sms en
racontant sa vie sexuelle avec d'autres
mecs
et des photos encore et des faits sans
précédent prises si on n'a pas le temps
présent oui mais plusieurs voix de lou
fille qui va juger une emprise non mais
c'est ce que j'avais tout c'est que
alors mac os que cette ascension
non queen's aussi si vous êtes fan il ya
forcément de l'emprise que le chanteur a
dirigé la prison c'est rien le dock dit
aussi que nous avant quand il commence
est choqué par le procureur c'est lui
qui dit aux deux jeunes filles d'écrire
des lettres en disant que non il n'a
jamais rien fait avec elle c'est faux et
que c'est ce que tous les cas il faudra
le prouver a eu le dock moi je suis pas
là moi ce que je veux vous dire aussi
c'est que il ya du nouveau et à numéros
qu'il faut pas l'info c'est trop vite et
lui il est serein il est sans cesse de
faire qu'ils ont laissé sortir ils l'ont
laissé sortir parce qu'il ya du nouveau
dans la sphère les avocats qui sont très
bons deux avocats dont une femme qui est
plutôt féministe qui défend les femmes
battues et c'est une ligne de conduite
où il ne peut munich pas d'accord que le
bond ne veut rien dire a fait personne
ne communique là dessus mais il faut
laisser faire les choses johnny depp
était foutu il ya un mois il faut voir
après moi je cautionne rien tout ça si
jamais déjà il ya une scie qui dit elle
s'est fait violer 50 fois bon si c'est
un violeur ce serait pas mon ami elle se
sera plus mon ami alors bon voilà
jean lui ils ont montré dans le
documentaire aussi que jean luc lahaye
n'hésitez pas à dire à la télé qu'il
aimait les jeunes filles regardez
tv l'homme
qui ne s'est jamais retourné vers une
fille de 20 ans au matin sa silhouette
vous êtes matt et
moi je vais plus augmenté bien sûr si je
peut se dire une fille de 20 ans je me
gêne pas bien sûr c'est mon signe
extérieur de jeunesse savez je suis pas
le seul artiste françois bien je
regardais gainsbourg enfin tout le monde
quoi il en parle très librement ils
l'assument mais il assume en général si
on devait parler de jeunes femmes plutôt
des femmes entre 23 25 ans on parle pas
effectivement de mineurs
c'est ça voilà c'est ça se dit laurent
c'est vrai qu'il a raison c'est ce qu'il
dit dans les oui et c'est vrai que cette
archive et là quelques années il ya
d'autres archives des années 80 des
années 90 et c'est vrai que certains
propos ne choquer personne à l'époque ça
c'était diffuser mon ça sur internet
mais l'une des grandes émissions télé
devant des millions de téléspectateurs
et ça ne choquer personne parce qu'on
était dans une société où il y avait des
chansons sur l'inceste où il y avait des
chansons sur des rapports avec des
mineurs et c'est vrai que c'est ça
témoigne aussi d'une certaine époque où
on pouvait dire des choses qui
aujourd'hui sont perçus comme atroce
soit la grèce met en examen donc il faut
le préciser pour viol et agression
sexuelle sur mineur on verra
l'instruction il risque 15 ans de prison
et vinci à des circonstances aggravantes
et lui n'y voit là il nie toute
brutalité tout viol il dit que c'était
des relations consenties c'est vrai
voilà d'être finie c'est votre ami donc
vous le défendez mais je voulais vous
demander qu'est ce que vous pensez des
parents qui libre à montpellier leur
fille parce qu'on a peur on a quand même
lu des articles où il avait marqué que
parfois les mères étaient même présents
tous dans la chambre à côté voire même
elle filmait qu'est ce que vous en
pensez marché scandaleux moi c'est déjà
j'ai les aurait mis en préventive au
moins un mois oui mais c'est quand même
votre ami qui fait ça au final cette
pratique non je pense que c'est un oubli
dans l'heure qui ont vécu un truc par
procuration quand parce qu'elles sont
sortis aussi avec lui un appareil donc
après j'étais peut-être trop âgé pour
lui je sais pas et elles ont pas voulu
lâcher la faire elles ont poussé leur
fille dans les bras mais là il ya un
truc qui se passe n'est pas normal qu'il
ya un problème d'éducation et tout mais
les maires là il faudrait les
responsabiliser un peu plus ça le
problème important est là mais c'est pas
chez les mères pour pousser donc vous
mettez la responsabilité sur les parents
pas sur votre ami quoi du coup
par rapport aux filles qu'elles ont
poussés dans les bras déjà 16 ans le
devrait moi je note que son projet ne
devrait pas être en boîte elle était
surtout les concerts c'est pour ça qu'il
les a fait monter sur scène juste marié
là parce qu'on le demande et à saint
tropez ya aucune
troupe et muriel pénale est elle morale
effectivement pénalement lui sur rtl il
dit à partir de 16 ans et la majorité
sexuelle la ville a 16 ans et un jour si
je me couchais avec et qu elle est
consentante vous ne pouvez rien pour
contre moi la loi est la raison mais
est-ce que vous moralement il ya des
preuves du moral moi c'est moralement
marge à 60 ans c'est une bombe je suis
avec depuis 34 ans dire que généralement
je répondais pas pourquoi c'est bien moi
non mais moi il n'ya pas que les pédales
dans tout ça moi je suis pas là alors je
suis pas là pour défendre jean luc
lahaye qu'on soit bien d'accord je suis
là pour défendre la présomption
d'innocence
point barre c'est à dire que tout le
monde ne s'emballe pas sur le sujet les
neuf ans qu'ils savaient qu'une fille de
16 ans et un mois reconnaissait que face
est décrite comme moi que ça choque
mais je le vois c'est pas mon truc mais
il se fait que je suis à saint tropez ou
ailleurs je vois 150 fois par jour à à
hawaï et des jeunes femmes à savoir
l'âge avec des gars de 60 ans et 16 ans
non je dis pas que saison en apparence
jeunes les femmes de 20 ans de 18 ans il
des gars de 60 ans j'en vois deux phares
scène différents 20 ans
et
une adolescente non mais là qu'il est
peut-être même pareil c'est qu'ils sont
14 ans c'était quoi tenter de porter
plainte quand il a couché avec elle il y
en avait une de 17 ans et une de saison
énorme et quand il fait monter sur scène
se pressent l'accablent passer pour une
chose c'est quand il dit viens viens à
la moto vient attendra la moto vient de
faire un bisou en vendant des photos à
lui dit à billets n'ont eu à vraiment
mais c'est pas sur moi même
16 ans elle a déjà sur lui moi je moi
j'adore je me plais pas ce que je vais
regarder à la télé d'où il vient
l'enfant de la dass qui réussit comme ça
pour moi c'est minable vous parlez de la
ds est ce que je peux faire juste une
parenthèse puisque que je sois pas venu
pour rien en ce qui concerne sa
fondation sa fondation il a fait trois
maisons il ya 130 enfants en ce moment
en permanence il ya 6 millions d'euros
de budget par an il a donné tous les
droits de son livre
2 millions d'exemplaires intégral pour
sa fondation essentielle dans la
fondation ses deux filles sont toujours
au conseil d'administration on l'a
débarqué comme dans la chanson
mais si vous voulez dans cette fondation
là en 37 ans l'a jamais reprocher quoi
que ce soit il a balancé tout sans
l'oseille là dedans donc il a fait aussi
des trucs bien et c'est pour ça qu'on
veut laisser la justice parce que tu
fais un truc bien qu il faut laisser la
justice se passe et wiba années passées
masse comme celle ci je suis là c'est
quand même c est un gars bien beau il
aime les jeunes femmes il s'est fait
piéger peut-être là je sais pas on verra
la nuit des rares mais il ya des
nouvelles choses
merci